Exclusive report on a
federal criminal investigation
into former President Donald Trump.
Attorneys for the former president
unable now
to locate a classified document
that he referenced on an audiotape
now in possession of prosecutors.
CNN's Kaitlan Collins is on the team
that broke this story.
She's joining us now with the latest.
Caitlin, take us through what we know
so what happened.
Here is
Maria Martin,
this press aide to former
President Trump,
who was in the White House
and now has followed him to Mar
a Lago, went
and testified
as many people who are in that orbit,
these days have gone before MS.
investigators.
And she was in there in mid-March.
And we're told
it was very shortly after she left
that grand jury testimony.
The prosecutor sent a subpoena
to the former president
saying that they wanted
any and all documents related to Iran.
And General Mark Milley,
the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff,
that Trump is referencing
on that audio recording
that we reported on on Wednesday.
And basically,
what I was told
that they were specifically seeking
was the document
that Trump is referencing on that tape.
Prosecutors made clear to Trump's
legal team that they wanted
that document.
Trump's team,
though, was unable to find it.
They did produce some materials,
we were told, in response
to this subpoena that they got
they could not find
that document, though.
That is at the heart
of what Trump was referencing.
So it's raised
a lot of questions
of where that document is.
I asked Trump's attorney the other day
if it had been sent back
to the National Archives,
what happened to it.
He declined to answer.
He also didn't say whether or not Trump
had declassified.
It is an argument they've been making.
So this is just raised questions
about this episode, which we know.
Jack Smith,
the special counsel, is very focused on.
I mean,
they even brought General Mark Milley
in to talk to him about this episode
because Trump was referencing him
when he was on that audio recording
discussing classified information.
All right, Caitlin, stay with us.
I want to bring in more
of our legal experts.
Elliot Williams, to you.
It is possible
that the Justice Department
recovered this document some other way.
How much does this document
actually matter when,
according to Caitlin's reporting,
the prosecutors do
have this audio tape of President Trump,
Trump himself talking about it?
Look, it doesn't
it doesn't write
the crime is retention of material
that is related to the national defense.
Now that
the crime doesn't say
that, you need to have the document there
in order to prosecute the person for it,
you just have to establish
the document went missing and someone
had it improperly.
Or retained it improperly.
Now, look,
this would be novel
to charge someone with a crime
for a document
that they're not in possession of.
But but a few things.
Number one,
the Defense Department likely
has a copy of it.
Number two,
you could get people
who made the document or are aware of it
to testify about where it was
and where it went until the point
at which it went missing.
So you can get around it a little bit
and they can find a way
to charge someone with a crime.
But it might just
require a little bit of creativity
from prosecutors.
So the former president
has been asked about this
missing document.
Here's what he had to say.
No, I don't know anything about it.
All I know is this.
Everything I did was right.
We have the Presidential Records Act,
which I abided by 100%.
I have the right
to declassify as president
because I have Secret Service
all over the place.
Mar a Lago is a fort
chain. Mar a Lago is a fort.
He's got Secret Service
all over the place.
Does that stand up in any way?
Well, that's kind of irrelevant
as to
whether he properly secured the document.
He allegedly should not have retained,
which he claims.
If I did have it, it was declassified.
That's kind of the problem for him.
He's all over the place
trying to cover all his bases.
The audiotape, as well as the subpoena
puts him in his legal team,
the difficult spot.
He's going to have to make
the Hobson's choice of saying either
I had this and was fine
for me to have it or
what are you talking about?
I was just blabbing on that tape.
But to do that,
he probably would have to testify.
And that's problematic for him
because you don't want him to testify.
He his lawyers could make that argument
if they got the court.
There's no proof
he really had that document.
He was just blowing hot air
as he likes to do.
But to make it really convincing,
the jury would
probably want to hear from them.
So that's a problem.
And in terms of the timing of Jack Smith,
the special counsel's investigation,
Elliot, where do you think we are
in terms of potential indictments?
There was one former
prosecutor predicting that indictment
could come within days.
Well, look, I
you know, it's hard to predict
when things will happen.
What I will say
is that we don't know what
the Justice Department has.
That's not public.
What is
public is a growing body
of statements from the former
president
leaks and other information
that have been reported
that seem to suggest
that at least
someone ought to be charged
with a crime in some way,
whether it's obstruction of justice
retention or removal of
sensitive information,
they could be charged.
And that's just based on
what's publicly available.
It's hard to even know what else
the Justice Department is sitting on.
So it could be imminent,
but we just don't know.
Is the Trump team
saying anything about what they think
the timeframe might be?
They have maintained that
they don't believe
there's a threat to him,
that they don't think
he'll be indicted in this case.
His former attorney,
who's no longer on the legal team, left
about two weeks ago,
downplayed
the idea that he would be indicted
the other day.
But behind the scenes,
based on our reporting,
what we have heard from people is
the tone has shifted since this
since we reported this on Wednesday.
I think they think the legal significance
of this,
they realize how grave it is
and that it could potentially
be a game changer
when it comes to this investigation.
They had been pretty confident.
They were almost joyous
when the documents
were found at Pence's home.
And the Biden documents
situation happened.
Very different situations, of course,
but they were almost joyous all that
because they thought it was essentially
a guarantee
that nothing
would happen to their client.
I think the people around the former
president are very worried
now that they know
Jack Smith has this audio.
They've known about this since March,
by the way.
They've been looking for this document.
That was when they got the subpoena
They realize the legal peril
that he's facing right now.
You mentioned how joyous they were
when more classified documents
were found
at President Biden's
residences and offices.
The former president,
Mike Pence's home as well.
But Evan, you've got new reporting.
Mike Pence has been cleared.
He has been cleared.
He got a letter.
His team got a letter yesterday.
That says
that the Justice Department,
the National Security
Division, have been investigating
this, a dozen
or so documents that were found.
And they've decided that
there are no charges to be brought
This obviously takes us back to January
when they added
an abundance of caution,
went looking for documents, partly
because of what had happened
with the former president, Donald Trump,
who had a special counsel appointed
as a result
of having declared that he was
running for president.
Merrick Garland
also appointed a special counsel
to look at the documents
related to to President Biden.
And so the question
has been hanging over this review
that has been ongoing,
this investigation,
whether Mike Pence would also end up
having a special counsel,
because as we know,
we're days away
from a likely announcement
from the vice president,
the former vice
president saying
that he is running for president.
So this clears the decks for him.
And look, again, as Caitlin pointed out,
the circumstances are so different.
Right.
Mike Pence finds these documents
Turns him over to
to the National Archives and the FBI
cooperates, fully
allows for searches to come
in, does not publicly claim
that that these documents
are his
completely different way
of handling this.
And you can see how quickly,
you know,
the Justice Department
can work through a situation like this
when you have this level of corruption.
To add one
point to that,
Pence affirmatively
went looking for documents.
He brought in his lawyers
to conduct a search of his property.
It's not that it was just inadvertent.
And they found these things
it's just a different class of conduct.
And you can't it's
not even apples and oranges.
It's just it's so vastly different
that I don't think
there was ever a likelihood
that Pence would have been.
Also worth noting.
Trump doesn't see it that way.
I don't think
that's surprising to anyone.
But he was posting about this today,
noting how Pence has been effectively
cleared by the DOJ, and he's asking
when that's going to happen to him.
It comes out,
as he does recognize that there is real
legal exposure that is facing him
with these recordings
that were done
by people
who are writing an autobiography
for his chief of staff at the time,
Mark Meadows, former
chief of Staff, Mark Meadows,
and now have put him in real hot water
and certainly something
that is going to come up
on the campaign trail.
A real contrast there.
We've got to leave it there, Evan.
Caitlin, Elliot, Chin,
thank you all very much.